I'll be honest with you I've talked to
some people that look absolutely they
look absolutely dreadful the guys are
really letting themselves go in general
the women are doing a much better job
you look fantastic
what are you doing to take care of
yourself I mean I'm talking about like
self-care you know moisturizing doing
things at home now that we can't go out
you you can't yeah moisturizing why
would you waste your lotions I know I
haven't moisturized once in my life
until I went into quarantine and then
that's all I've got you know sleeping
ten hours a night which is fantastic
I haven't been I haven't been doing my I
really need a haircut I really need a
haircut
I didn't think wait what was this okay
I'm gonna have the editors look back at
that so you wait you look fine until you
started to push it forward well I had
bangs see before this started and now
they clearly grown out and Tom my
husband is too scared to cut them
because he's afraid that I'll get mad at
him so then I thought hey Conan seems to
know a lot about hair nah maybe he could
help me out with cutting right I mean
really I feel like you probably think
more about hair than that than the
average Joe I think more about hair than
the average hairstylist lots of work has
gone into this over the years
it's your trademark that means
automatically like there's I would trust
you Kate Middleton timet a shallow mate
those are the journeys all primarily
known for their beautiful hair yes thank
you it's nice to be in that elite group
by the way the only way I can make my
daughter laugh
now is when we watch a movie with
Timothy sha'lame whenever he walks on
screen I go
and she laughs that's the only thing
I've ever done that she finds funny
don't know I don't think you should be
messing with your hair your hair looks
good coming I just think like I'm not
going back to work anytime soon we have
at least a couple months I would like to
have a cute fringe as they say over here
help me do it okay how would I do that
would you have any instruments with you
do you have clippers yeah hedge clippers
you could get it you won chopped no
Clippers makes me a little nervous
that's for the short man's hair or a
short haircut but no I have um Tom made
this this charity thing this beautiful
rainbow these scissors like really they
were truly just right here on this
rainbow they're obviously for paper I
don't think they're for hair but they
seem fairly sturdy and I trust you I'm
gonna say I've done some scary things in
my career I've never been more
frightened you're a very attractive
woman and the idea of me over a zoom
line here in LA cutting your hair with
not even the right scissors is is
horrifying to me
I don't know that scissors make it less
horrifying oh there's no way it would be
less horrifying layers oh I think you
have to keep it that way right there and
then do it well hold on if you want the
right yes I am what like keep it like
that and then you have to do but you
have one strand that's much longer than
the other okay okay okay I can't get rid
of it we're gonna layer it we're gonna
layer it we're gonna do see that strand
right there
yeah just cut a little off of that
strand okay like where that's good yep
no no right there just cut that off okay
then mail that to me and don't ask why
[Laughter]
hold on you want the bangs trim you want
the straight-across you're not gonna
move you are are you willing to take
that whole chunk off right there if you
pull it down right now
no bangs I would like to have my bangs
back okay all right so pull it down past
there and how high do you want them oh
my god this is nerve-racking this is
like talking someone down who's piloting
a 747 that's what it feels like to me
right now something up here but I don't
know what so let's just keep going we're
not gonna worry about that all right
hold that right there
now do you want it to be right around
where your brows are I don't mind a baby
Bane okay let's do this
you can always take off more but you can
never add someone's home true
haircutting Pro so start there and just
take off bring your hand down right to
about there and just take off from go up
a little further and from there up there
oh god this scares me so much yeah go
it's now
working is it Oh God Oh God
okay Oh God : it's not bad you know what
I have to say something that is not bad
it is not a minister yeah yeah cuz I'm
okay
you'd have to go straight across please
close your eyes no no that's what you
can you're gonna you're gonna look like
Moe from The Three Stooges
also who cares stakes couldn't be lower
well no pandemic could end tomorrow and
they could say hey we want you to play
Rapunzel a big Disney remake and they
they say would but Conan cut my hair
from ten thousand miles away
okay it's a little low over the right
eye over here no no no it's too that's
too much lower there you go right around
there I think go okay yes yeah you do
look like Will Ferrell in Zoolander
though well that's a hole oh yeah that's
you know what you need to do you get get
some shoe polish yeah
it's covered in that part this is thank
you
are you sure this is everything you can
do I mean there's okay a little more of
the eyes just a little more just a
little more this is killing me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah wait I think that really
messed it up
no it's see there's just a little part
that comes down right on the bridge of
your nose it comes down a little far
yeah I don't want to cut my
lots of it now I'm really blind how's it
look you know what it looks good it
looks good I'm all its look I'm gonna be
honest with you I think you look amazing
if you go into a professional stylist
right now yeah allowed to they would say
who did this to you and there'd be a
warrant out for me that looks amazing
it's like Audrey Hepburn hair yes no I'm
gonna say it's Roman Holiday you look
like
like Audrey Hepburn in Roman Holiday you
look you look gorgeous now let's do you
yeah isn't that funny there's no here I
can just pull mine down you know mine
anyone I know I know I need a little
trim but I got I got nothing here look
at this oh yes I need that I want to
yeah yeah I'm a kid that would come and
ask you for a date who has no shot it's
Lizzie here tell her Conan called
and Karl came by and I just was
wondering if maybe she wanted to go get
him malted is that a guy that's a guy
that's a guy dating age I'm not kidding
I like it
I think it's really good I think I just
saved your life and your career
thank you so much I'm telling you people
are gonna see this and they're gonna be
these big deal producers see let's see
this and go that's the look we always
thought of Lizzie as having that kind of
hair but now she's got this hair and
that's perfect
you've opened up so many doors for me
today now for the first time since this
all happened I'm looking forward to life
after the Panda all right well I hope
people out there like it because people
really do love you and if they don't
like what has happened here they're
going to hate my
and guys I'm telling you I thought this
was gonna when I thought maybe code
should help me with my hair I thought it
was gonna go really bad and as it turns
out beautiful yeah well you know me good
at everything
let's get exhausted